hi I'm David Quang and I'm a magician
and I've taken magic and I've broken it
down into the seven principles of
illusion and I'm gonna show you how you
can use them in your everyday life but
first watch this see most magicians
pretend in some way or another to have
superpowers
but I don't I acknowledge right up front
that magic is tricks how did I bend the
spoon well first you need to understand
that your brain is a liar
there's so much information in the world
your brain cannot handle it all so in
order to function it takes shortcuts it
makes assumptions like this spoon is one
piece it's actually two
your brain sees point a and point B and
concludes that a single spoon is running
through it
neuroscientists call this a modal
completion between what you see and what
you believe is a gap which is how we get
our first principle mind the gap
magicians like to play around in this
[Music]
I'd like to teach you a trick that you
can try on your friends and I'll
demonstrate it for you first it involves
a selection of playing cards I'll
dribble them down like this and you
would just tell me when to stop so let's
say you say stop right here and you
would remember this good a little bit of
a shuffle and I should be able to get
your card to rise out of the middle of
the deck just
this so how did this work well it starts
with another principle which is write
the script because I wanted you to
believe that your card came out of the
middle of the deck I use specific
language to convey that and then I
showed you this image of the card in the
middle magicians
manipulate your memory of what happened
because your card did not come out of
the middle of the deck it came from the
top of the deck but how was I able to
secretly get your card to the top of the
deck I loaded up load up is a magicians
term for doing all the prep work ahead
of time what was the heavy lifting that
I used in this magic trick
I took 52 decks and removed the four of
clubs from each of them and loaded them
into this deck then there's the illusion
of free choice which we are able to
design even though you think you picked
the four clubs freely it was your only
choice if you as the audience member
believe that you are in control that you
are dictating how the trick goes you
will buy into the illusion more even
though I had this stacked deck of four
of clubs how was I able to convince you
that it was a normal deck well I played
into your brains need to respond to
patterns we employ the familiar I showed
you the first few cards and from there
you extrapolated that the deck was
normal but what do you do when
everything goes wrong what do you do if
perhaps your volunteer chooses one of
these three cards instead well
magicians always have a back-up plan and
we call that having an out if you were
to choose the seven of diamonds or the
Queen of Spades or the six of Hearts you
have to have those outs ready to go and
I have the seven of diamonds here in my
pocket
the Queen of Spades in my back and the
six of Hearts is just hanging out
back here behind the easel magicians
have for every trick three or four
backup plans ready to go and there's one
more principle of illusion a magician's
best friend misdirection
we call it control the frame it's like a
film directors frame this is the center
of your attention and we can move the
frame like if I wanted to steal
something out of my left pocket I might
move the frame over here as I pick up a
pen out of the cup these are the seven
principles of illusion and you can try
to use them in your own life one more
thing
did you notice how I was able to control
the frame during this video check this
out
Cheers
[Music]
you